All right.
Last time we started asking ourselves
about what are some of the other aspects
of death that might contribute to its
badness or at least other features of
death that are worth thinking about.
Conceivably,
some of them might reduce the
badness of death in some way.
We talked about the
inevitability of death.
We talked about the variability that
people have different lengths of time
before they die and we turn
to the discussion of the
unpredictability of death.
The fact that because we don't know,
we can't predict how much
more time we've got. We May,
as it were,
pace ourselves incorrectly.
We may take on a longterm project,
uh,
and then die before you've
been able to complete it.
Or alternatively you made sort of peak
too soon and then a sort of continue to
stick around in an anticlimactic way.
These are bads of life that
could presumably be avoided
if only we knew how much
exactly we had,
how much longer we had.
And the other hand we
have to ask ourselves,
and this is a question that
I left us with last time,
whether it would really
all things considered,
be better to know how much time
you had after all, if you knew,
suppose we had the, the, the birthmarks
that told you when you were going to die,
if you had that kind of a birthmark,
you would face your entire life with the
burden of knowing I've got, you know,
48 years left, 47 years, left
50 have ears, let you know,
I should've been counting
down 35, 30, 25 and so forth.
Many of us would find that,
uh, or as they say, a burden,
something hanging constantly over us,
interfering with our
ability to enjoy life.
Suppose that there were some
sort of genetic marker. Uh,
and although we didn't have a tattoo
that you just have to look at,
but you could have genetic counseling
and have the right kind of Da,
have your DNA examined and you could
tell if you had the DNA testing,
how much time you had left,
would you want to get that testing done?
Now that's of course science fiction
and I presume it's going to stay science
fiction though we're on the cusp of having
something at least approximating that
as we learn more and more
about the various genes that
carry a various diseases.
Uh,
we more and more of us face the question
of whether or not we want to get tested
for those diseases.
Suppose there was a test date will
occasionally reads in the newspaper about
this sort of thing where you can get
tested for such and such a disease.
You might know already that you've
got a 50% chance of having it,
but you don't know whether you
yourself have it. If you do have it,
you know the disease will always have
onset by age 40 50 or what have you.
Would you want to have that
kind of information closely?
Related question.
If you did know how
much time you had left,
how would you act differently
from what you're doing now?
Would it,
would it focus your attention on making
sure you did the things that were most
important to you?
And it's worth in sort of a
useful test for asking yourself,
what are the things you
most value in life to ask?
What would you choose to do if
you knew you had five years,
10 years, what have you.
There's an old Saturday,
Saturday night live routine where uh,
uh,
one of the actors is in the
doctor's office and the,
and the doctor gives him the very sad
news that he's got two minutes left to
live.
Uh,
and he says I'm going to pack a
lifetime of enjoyment into those,
those two minutes.
And then of course the point of the skid
as he presses the down button on the
elevator and the minute and a half goes
by while he's waiting for the elevator
to come. If you knew you had
a year left or two years left,
what would you do with that time?
Would you be in school?
Would you travel?
Would you spend more time hanging
out with your friends? Uh, a very,
uh,
for me,
extremely striking example of this
question occurred in this very class.
There was a student in this class some
years ago who was dying and he knew that
he was dying. He'd been diagnosed with,
if I recall correctly, cancer, uh,
as a freshmen.
And his doctor had told him that he
pretty much had no chance of recovery and
indeed had only a couple more years
to live faced with that question.
He had to ask himself, well, what
should I do with my remaining years?
It was astonishing enough that somebody
perhaps understandable that somebody in
that situation would decide to take a
class on death and then have himself sort
of submit himself to my getting up
here week after week talking about how
there's no soul, there's no
prospect for an afterlife. Uh,
it's a good thing that
we're all going to die.
But faced with the question
of what should he do,
what did he want to do with
his remaining couple of years?
What he decided he wanted to
do was finish, is Yale degree.
Thought he'd set himself the goal of
graduating college before he died.
And he was taking this class
second semester of his senior year,
at least he was taking it until
spring break. By spring break,
he'd gotten sufficiently sick
that his doctor basically said,
you can't continue in school anymore.
You've got to go home. Basically.
You've got to go home to die.
Uh,
and indeed he got progressively and
then rapidly deteriorated at that point.
There's the faculty members who were
teaching his classes that semester.
Then all face the question posed
to them by the administration.
They start on the work he's done
so far this semester. Has He,
what kind of grade, uh, do you,
are you prepared to give him?
Because depending on which of his classes
he passed and which of his classes he
failed, the question was going to be, you
know, was he going to graduate or not?
In fact, of course he did
manage to graduate and Yale too.
It's a,
I think we will glory and credit sent a
member of the administration down to his
deathbed to award him, uh, his
degree before he passed away.
So let's say it's a very striking story.
I'm not sure how many of us would decide.
The last thing we wanted to do with
our remaining years is to spend it in
college. Well, what is it that
you'd want to do? And again,
to move back and ask ourselves the larger
question would knowing how much time
you have be something that would allow
you to actually embrace those choices or
would it instead just be a burden?
That's the kind of question we have to
face when we think about the fact that we
don't know how much time we've gone.
Is that something that increases the
badness of death or does it reduce its
significance somewhat.
Here's another feature in
addition to the inevitability,
in addition to the variability,
in addition to the unpredictability,
there's the fact that death is,
as I like to think of it ubiquitous.
I don't just mean the fact that
people are dying all around us,
but I mean rather you yourself
could die at any time.
There never any getting away from
the possibility that you'll die now,
even if we didn't have unpredictability.
I mean whether even if
we had unpredictability,
it wouldn't necessarily follow that
death was pervasive in this way.
The point I've got in mind here is this,
even when you think you're perfectly safe,
you could of course die of a stroke.
You could die of a heart attack.
Even somebody who's young could have an
aneurysm or one of my favorite examples.
You can be sitting in your,
you've sort of read this sort of
thing in the liver and the newspaper.
Periodically you can be sitting in your
living room when suddenly an airplane
crashes into your house,
killing you,
the sorts of things happen.
You thought you were safe,
you are watching reruns on television.
The next minute you're dead.
The fact that you could die and you don't
know when you're going to die doesn't
yet in tale that you could die
at any minute at any moment,
but in fact that's true of us as well.
Get another example. Close to my heart.
I remember before I taught here,
I used to teach at the University of
Illinois at Chicago and once I was driving
down the highway and a car
pulled in without looking, uh,
and clipped my car, uh, and caused
my cock pulled in from the entrance,
caused my car to go careening
across three lanes of traffic,
spinning out of control.
And I remember quite clearly
thinking to myself as that happened,
the whole thing lasted only a few moments,
but I remember thinking quite clearly
I'm going to die. Uh, now as it happens,
I didn't die.
I walked away from the accident and the
damage to my car was rather minimal,
but it could have happened like that.
Death is the possibility
of death is ubiquitous.
It's pervasive.
We have to ask ourselves then,
does this make things worse?
It certainly feels to my mind is though
it's an extra bad about the nature of
death.
It would be nice to get a breather.
Imagine if you will,
that there were certain locations,
certain vacation spots where you,
as long as you were there,
you couldn't die.
Wouldn't it be nice to be able to go
someplace and just for a period think to
yourself, well, you know right now
I don't have to worry about it.
It doesn't even have to cross my mind.
Maybe if there were these sort of death
free zones, they'd get rather crowded,
so perhaps we should change the example
instead of having death free zones
imagined that there were death free times.
Just suppose to,
for whatever reason,
nobody could die between 12 and one.
You could just sort of put it out of your
mind. Wouldn't that be nice? All right.
One o'clock sort of you
take the mantel back on,
but wouldn't it be nice to just have a
certain period of time every day when you
didn't have to even have it be so much
as a remote possibility or supposed to
wear a certain death free activities?
Maybe reading philosophy
would be something that as
long as you were doing it,
you couldn't die or, or as perhaps some
religious traditions might've taught.
As long as you are engaged in prayer,
you couldn't, you couldn't tie.
Wouldn't that be nice or are turned
the entire thing the other way around.
Suppose that most times and
most activities were death free,
but certain activities introduce
the possibility of dying.
So you couldn't die unless you
were engaged in certain activities.
So you would be immortal, but not in
a sense of immortal against you will.
There'll be certain activities
perhaps, you know, for example,
putting a gun to your head,
that would put an end to your life.
So even if more immortality would be bad,
there'll be certain things you
could do that could end it.
Okay.
Ask Yourself,
what sorts of activities would you engage
in if you knew that those activities
carried with it,
carried with them the risk of dying.
So most of the time you couldn't die.
What things would be so important to
you that you'd be willing to suddenly
risked death for the sake of doing things?
You like? Art? Is Art important enough to
you? Uh, that you'd be prepared to watch?
Look at a masterpiece. If you knew that
while you were enjoying it, you could die,
but that wouldn't happen otherwise.
Is Sex great enough that you'd be prepared
to run the risk of dying while you
were engaged in sex? Again, it's
a nice lens for asking yourself,
what are the things that
are most valuable to you?
By asking which of them are so valuable,
you'd be prepared to do them even if
they would introduce what isn't the
otherwise there namely the risk of death
now and posing the question that way.
I've been assuming that these are things
you do despite the fact that they run
the risk of death. I suppose there
is a further question we have to ask.
Are there things that would be worth
doing precisely because of the fact that
they introduced the risk of death?
Now I've got to admit that
when I posed that question,
that sounds rather bizarre.
At least you know,
putting aside the possibility that we've
now lived are a hundred thousand years
and have exhausted all that life's got
to offer for us certainly to engage in
activities now.
Well,
life still has so much more to offer to
engage in activities now where precisely
for the chance of dying.
That strikes me as bizarre.
And yet it seems to me that
there are many activities,
if not many,
at least several activities that
people do precisely for that reason.
For example, let me tell you something.
I know there's going to shock you.
Did you know there are people
who jump out of airplanes now,
admittedly, they've got this
little piece of cloth, uh,
that gives them a decent chance of not
killing themselves when they jump out of
airplanes. But these things
do fail every now and then.
He sort of read in the newspaper about
somebody who's parachute failed to open
it, so they died. I asked myself why,
what could possibly drive somebody to,
to jump out of an airplane with nothing
but a little piece of cloth between them
and death?
And the answer that tracks me,
his most plausible is it's this very
fact that there's a significant chance of
death that helps explain
why people do this. Now,
I know if you talked to some of these
people, they'll often say, oh, no, no, no,
the views are so glorious,
or something like that.
But I think this is rather an implausible
suggestion because of course you could
have these glorious views just by going
up in the airplane and looking down from
the safety of your airplane.
Part of the thrill has got to be,
or so it seems to me part of the thrill
has got to be the very fact that they
now have an increased risk of death.
The chance of dying is part of what drives
somebody to jump out of an airplane.
Well,
if that's right then should we say
that the pervasiveness of death,
the ubiquitousness of death,
the thing that I was earlier
suggestion was oppressive.
Wouldn't it really be nice to have a
death free time or Jeffrey location are
debt free activities?
Maybe I was wrong and suggesting that if,
if the chance of death
would add kind of zest,
then perhaps the ubiquity of death is
actually a good thing rather than a bad
thing. I'm inclined to think, at least
in my own case, that that's not right.
Um, perhaps the explanation has got to
be the ubiquity of death is this kind of
background constant. Hum. Uh, and,
uh,
the fact that we are always facing
some risk of death recedes into the
background or the way that most
of us don't hear background noise.
The what jumping out of an
airplane does for you is it,
it's spikes the risk of death.
So it's not really good enough
to just have some risk of death.
It's gotta be greater risk than usual,
if that's right.
If that's the psychology,
then even for those death,
death thrill seekers of ubiquity of
death won't necessarily be a good thing
because of it being constant,
it just recedes into the background.
All right,
so again,
what had been asking us to think about
our various aspects of death that might
contribute to either increase or perhaps
in certain ways reduced somewhat the
badness of death.
There's one more aspect that I want to
take a couple of minutes and have us
think about, and that's this.
Look previously to this,
this most recent discussion I
talked about the value of life,
some rival theories about
what makes life worth living.
And now for the last lecture or so I've
been talking about in addition to the
deprivation account,
the additional things that
contribute to the badness of death.
So you might think, well, what about
the human condition as a whole?
What about the fact that it's not
just that we live or for that matter,
it's not just that we die?
What's true about humans is
that we live and then we die.
That's the human condition.
Life followed by death might ask what's
the value of that entire combination?
Now, the most natural
thing to suggest would be,
well, you know, you get clear on your,
your favorite theory about the
value of life, whatever that is,
you get clear about the kinds of
questions we've just been asking about the
badness of death,
whatever that is.
What's the overall assessment of the
human condition? You might think,
well that's just a matter of adding up
the goodness of life and subtracting the
badness of death and summing it.
Whatever comes to
I suppose again, kind of optimist
says, know, yeah, death is bad,
but life is good,
sufficiently good to outweigh the badness
of the fact that we're going to die on
balance. It's a good thing to be born and
pessimists might be those who say, no,
no, I'm balanced. The negative of death
outweighs the positiveness of life,
but I want to pause for a moment and and
note that this assumption that the way
to think about the value of the
combination is just a matter of adding the
goodness of life and the badness of
death and just summing them that way.
That may not be right because sometimes
the value of a combination is different
than the value you would get by just
thinking about each one of the parts in
isolation and then adding them up.
I kind of addition approach to values
of holes may not always be correct.
Here's a nice simple
example to make that point.
My two favorite foods in the world
are probably pizza on the one hand and
chocolate on the other. I know I've shared
my love of chocolate with you before.
I don't recall having shared my love of
pizza with you before, but there it is.
Two favorite things. I Love, Love Pizza,
delicious love chocolate, delicious.
Take these two delicious
things and combine them into
a chocolate covered pizza.
I'm like, God, the whole idea
just sounds disgusting and it is.
I take it disgusting,
but you wouldn't notice the disgusting
this if you just thought about the value
of pizza in isolation and the
value of chocolate in isolation,
the value of chocolate covered pizza
is not just a matter of summing up the
value of the parts and
I'd taken in isolation.
You've got to think about what we
might dub the interaction effects.
So let's ask ourselves,
are there any interaction effects when
we talk about the human condition that
it's life followed by death. We've thought
about the value of life in isolation.
We've been in effect thinking about
the value of death in isolation.
Does the fact that death follows life,
does that produce any interaction
effects between the two,
which need to be added into our formula
added into the mix as well? Well,
there's obviously I suppose
two possibilities. Well,
really three possibility number one is no,
doesn't make any difference.
Uninteresting possibility.
More interestingly to
remaining possibilities. Yeah.
There is actually some ways in which
the combination ends up becoming worse.
The interaction effects make things
even worse than we can't overlook.
Those interact,
those negative interaction effects.
Also the possibility that there might
be some positive interaction effects.
Let me start briefly by mentioning a
possibility for a positive interaction
effect
because of the fact that you're
going to die obviously enough.
It's not just the he'll
get whatever life you get,
but there's a finite amount of
life that you're going to get.
Life is a scarce resource.
It's precious and we might be attracted
to the thought that the value of life is
increased by its very preciousness.
There's a kind of aspect of value for
many of us where we feel that some things
especially valuable,
if it won't endure,
if it's fragile or if it's rare,
this can enhance the value of something.
And so arguably the fact
that life is precious,
that it won't endure,
could actually increase it's value for us.
There's a short story by
the science fiction writer,
Orson Scott Card,
uh,
where the basic point of the story
is that of all the life forms in the
universe,
we here on earth are the
only ones that are mortal.
And because of this,
we are the envy of the
rest of the universe.
It's not so much that in mortality,
what the rest of them have is unattractive
or boring. It's perfectly fine.
But they envy us for our finite lifespans
because what we've got and they don't
have is something that sort
of for each individual rare,
something that not lasting,
something that's precious in that way.
All right?
It's a possibility.
So it's possible that the very fact
that we're going to die sort of has,
it causes an interaction effect
with our life. So as there's a,
there's an upside to it. It makes
our life fragile, ephemeral,
and as a result of that,
more precious.
But it's also possible actually
compatible with accepting that fact.
There are two additional possibilities
that there might be some negative
interaction affects.
It could be that they're in thinking
about the nature of the combination.
We're led to see that in certain
ways that the combination,
the interaction effects are, are
negative or bad ones. So here's,
here's two possibilities for that thought.
First possibility I think of under
the heading a taste is just a tease.
It's,
it's as though we live life for a while,
getting a feel for all the wonderful
things life could offer us and then a
moment later as it were,
it's snatched away from us.
It's sort of adding insult to injury that
we w we were that were offered just a
weird,
it's as though somebody brought in this
delicious meal to are hungry before a
hungry person.
Allow them to see what it looked like.
Allow them just smell the, you
know, the, the delicious aromas.
Perhaps gave them just one little tiny
forkful to see just how beautifully
delicious the food was and then
they snatched the whole thing away.
You can imagine somebody who says,
look,
it would be better never to have had the
taste at all than to have the taste and
then not be allowed to
have the entire meal.
That's something that you might not
notice if you just focus on the intrinsic
nature of the taste after
all the intrinsic nature of
the taste was positive or
if you just focused on the intrinsic
character of the not having a meal after
all,
not having to meet those just you know,
an absence of a certain experience to
capture what's excrutiatingly undesirable
about the two.
You need to think about the
two in combination to an
interaction effect and when
my thing look this,
this is one of the negative things about
the human condition that we get a taste
of life, nothing more before it
snatched away. That's one possibility.
The second possible thought that comes
to mind for me and thinking about the
negative interaction effects.
I call under the the,
the title I think about under the title
how the noble have fallen. I mean,
right now there's
something amazing about us.
We are people
in the universe. We, oh, you know, who
knows what is out there in the universe,
but at least in her on earth,
we may well be the only people there are,
ah,
who knows, maybe dolphins or or, or
a certain, some of the great apes,
but at the very rate,
it's a rather select club.
We are, as I said, you know, early in the
semester when I sent him a physical list,
I believe that people are just machines,
but we're not just any old machine.
We're amazing machines.
We're able to love,
we're able to write poetry.
We're able to think about the farthest
reaches of the universe and ask what our
place is in the universe.
People are amazing and we end up rotting.
We end up corpses.
There's some thing for many of us,
there's something horrifying about the
thought that something as amazing as us
as exalted and valuable as us could end
up something as lowly and unimportant as
a piece of rotting flesh. It
again, think about it, you know,
uh,
I,
the imagery that comes to mind for me is
one of these deposed kings who ends up
waiting on a tables to make a living.
You know, in New York and you,
and it's,
you might think are the light of a way.
There's not the worst thing in the
world, but there's extra, again,
insult to injury when the person's got
to remember that he used to be something
extraordinary. A ruler. Again,
if you just thought about life as a ruler,
well,
pretty good thinking
about it in isolation.
Life has a waiter not so bad
thinking about it in isolation,
to see the nature of the,
of the problem,
you've got to think about the fact
that it's a combination package.
There's something especially insulting
about having gone from king to waiter how
the mighty have fallen and that fate
before is waiting for all of us.
It's a fact about the human condition
that the amazing things we are don't stay
amazing.
We turn into pieces of rotting flesh,
decaying.
So two possible negative effects.
The taste is just a tease. The how
the noble have fallen on the one hand,
one possible positive effect, uh, that
sort of extra preciousness of life.
I'm not quite sure where on
balance we should say, uh,
how these things play out.
Again,
I suppose we could have different
views. On the one hand, the,
the optimists might say,
even when we throw in the
extra interaction effects,
even the negative interaction affects
the overall nature of the human condition
is positive so that it's a good thing to
be born even though your life is going
to be followed by death.
And against that we could have
the pessimists who say the,
the negative side, especially once we
throw into negative interaction effects,
the negative side is so great that it
would be better never to have been born at
all.
That's the pessimist view,
given that we're going to die this,
this fact seeps back in and poisons the
nature of life or perhaps poisons the
nature of the,
of the,
of the whole life followed
by death so that unbalanced,
the whole thing's negative.
Better to have not had any event betters,
have not been born at all,
say the pessimists then to have this
combination package of life followed by
death.
Now for myself,
I'm sufficiently optimistic that I'm
inclined to think life's wonderful.
The negative combination effects that I
was talking about are certainly there,
but on balance I think the
human condition for most of us,
there's a good one better to
have been born there never had,
even though that's followed by death
than never to have been born at all,
but I do want to emphasize the point
that even if we were to accept the
conclusion that it would be better
never to have been born at all.
It doesn't follow,
at least doesn't follow without further
argument that the right response to the
realization if it is
the correct realization,
that'd be better narrative been
born at all. It doesn't follow that.
The right response is to commit suicide
to tempting thought, right? To Go
philosophically from life's so bad,
given the nature of the human condition
life followed by death that better to
never have had any of it. Then they've
just had a taste and a tease and so forth.
But it's a tempting philosophical thought
to say once I've shown it's better
never to have been born. It follows that
suicide is the appropriate response,
but in fact, as a matter of
logic, that doesn't follow it all.
Because if you think about it,
suicide doesn't change the fundamental
nature of the human condition.
Life followed by death.
It's not as though if you kill yourself,
you somehow bring it about that
you've never been born at all.
It's still the case that if
there's something horrible
about having just a taste,
well indeed, if you commit suicide,
you've made it an even shorter chased.
If there's something sort of
degrading or an unknowable about,
uh,
being a person who's going to become a
corpse committing suicide doesn't alter
that fundamental fact either.
It just makes the insult comes sooner.
So, even if we were to agree
with the pessimists that
it would be better never to
have been born at all. Uh, you
know, as, as the old joke goes,
show me one person in a
thousand who so lucky, right?
We have all been born and from the fact,
even if we were to agree with it,
that it would have been
better if we hadn't been born.
Instead of feeling sorry for unborn Larry,
perhaps we should end the unborn Larry.
That's what the pessimists say.
Even if that were true,
it wouldn't follow that suicide
was an inappropriate response.
It doesn't mean, of course it's suicide
isn't ever inappropriate response.
You know,
we're,
we're coming on towards the end of the
semester and the last topic we'll be
talking about is indeed
the topic of suicide. When,
if ever is suicide and
appropriate rational or moral
response to one situation.
Let's hold off on thinking about that
question a bit further before we get to a
suicide might say,
look,
the question that's going to entertain
us for the remaining few weeks is this.
How should one live in light
of the facts about death?
That I'd been laying out in
the semester up to this point.
How should we live in light of the facts
about death and one possible response.
The last one we'll look
at is what you should do,
at least sometimes is kill yourself.
Come to that.
Well, we're going to spend it the next
couple of weeks asking ourselves different
aspects of the question.
What should our response be to the fact
of our death and the specific features
of death and the nature of
death that we'd been exploring.
Okay.
But the very first question I suppose
we really need to ask is this,
should we be thinking about
all of this at all? Well,
I realize that for you
guys, it's too late, right?
It's sort of late in the day for students
who've been through the better part of
a semester, uh, thinking about the nature
of death to argue, maybe, you know,
it was such a good idea for you to
take this class in the first place.
But you know,
as as theorists,
we could be interested in the theoretical
possibility that the right response is
to not think about the facts
of death at all. In principle,
in principle, I suppose there's
three different reactions. Yup.
So, so I make various claims of the
sort that I've been making about,
well look, you know, we're just physical
objects. When these objects break,
we cease to exist. The objects don't
get put back together, you know,
and so forth and so on.
One possibility of course is simply
to disagree with me about the facts.
And so you of course, if you do
disagree, I think you're mistaken.
So I'll think of us denying the facts,
but that's a possibility.
Another possibility,
the one I'll turn to a little bit later
is admit the facts and live accordingly.
Of course, we haven't yet asked
ourselves, how should you live?
If you recognize and take
into account those fats,
that's the question we'll turn to.
But there's the,
there's the middle possibility,
which is not so much think about them and
deny them not so much think about them
except them and act accordingly.
But simply don't think about them.
Okay.
Maybe the best response,
ted,
the facts of death are just
put it out of your mind.
Don't give it any thought at all.
No.
On the one hand,
you might think that can't
possibly be the right response,
the appropriate response after all,
how can it be appropriate to disregard,
to put out of your mind facts?
Well,
that all sounds very nice, but I think
that claims got to just be mistaken.
There's nothing unacceptable
or inappropriate or
misguided about not thinking
about all sorts of facts that you might
have learned at some point or the other.
Here's my favorite
example of stupid facts.
I was forced to learn when I was
younger state capitols, right?
I've gotten pretty far in my life and
as far as I can tell, I've never ever,
ever had to remember the
capitals of the 50 states.
Yeah,
so I just don't think
about it pretty much.
I think about it only once a year
when I'm giving this very lecture.
I started asking the how many k say
capital's can I remember in the answer is
really not all that many of them not
thinking about those facts that I knew at
one point,
just not all that objectionable,
so in a matter of fact if it is a fact,
you know,
suppose the facts about life and death
are as I've described them until we say
something more, it's not clear
that we shouldn't just, all right,
just note it stored away
from getting about it.
Just like the facts about the
state capitals, that seems odd,
that seems misguided,
but why?
What is it about thus the facts about
life and death that seemed to make it
misguided to think we should just put
them aside and pay no attention to them?
Presumably because we're,
we're led to the thought or tracked into
the thought that the nature of death,
the facts about death,
whatever they are should have
an impact on how we live.
The appropriate way to live,
get shaped,
at least in part by the fact that we're,
that we're going to die,
that we won't be around forever.
If that's right,
then it seems as though
there'd be something irrational
and inappropriate about
simply disregarding those facts.
Let me,
let me tell you two stories that might,
well look before I tell you the
stories, here's, here's the other side.
Suppose somebody said, yeah, it's true.
If I thought about the nature of death,
the fact that you know,
the 50 80 90 years I've got on
this earth is all on gone ahead.
If I thought about that fact,
it would just be overwhelming.
It would be crushing.
I'd be unable to sort
of go on with my life.
People sometimes claim that that's
the case and because of that,
the the right thing to do is to
not think about it. You know,
you've read at this point,
you know,
long since a total stories
death of Ivan Illich,
then the people in the toll story story
seem to have put the facts of mortality
out of their mind. Why?
Presumably because they,
they think that facing it is just
to crushing and overwhelming.
So the way they cope with it, they think
the appropriate responses, put it aside,
disregard the facts about death.
Oh,
does it say that there's seems to be
something Amiss about that reaction?
That was certainly the point.
That toll was trying to get us to see
there's something wrong about lives,
something inauthentic about lives that
are lived without facing the facts of our
mortality and living accordingly. Whatever
the appropriate responses might be.
Here are, here are two stories not
having to do with death per se,
that may help us get a feel for the
oddity of trying to disregard these facts.
So Paul is that you're on a hot date or
about to go out on a hot day with Peggy
sue. Oh. Or, or depending on your
preferences. Billy Bob, uh, and,
and your roommate holds
up an envelope and says,
written in this envelope are certain
facts about Peggy sue or Billy Bob.
I, I'm not going to tell you what these
facts are yet. They're in the envelope,
but I'll give you the envelope.
You can open it up and read them.
But I do want to tell you
this, this one thing, it is,
it is indeed the case that if
you were to read these facts,
if you were to think about these facts,
if you were to know the things
written down in the envelope,
you would not want to
go out with Peggy sue
and you say to yourself,
well,
let's see right now I want to go out
with Peggy sue. But if I knew these true,
it's not that you think, oh, your roommate
has made it up, that these are lies.
These are slander.
You really believe and you're,
and it is in fact the case that the things
written down in the envelope are true.
And so you know that if only you were
to read these things in the envelope,
you would change your mind and no
longer want to go out with her.
And so what you say is,
don't show me the envelope
that seems odd,
doesn't seem like it makes sense.
If there are things that would change
your mind and you know that they would
change your mind about your behavior,
how can it be rational to disregard them?
Here's another story.
You're about to drink a milkshake and
your roommate comes rushing in and say,
I've got the lab report.
I had said my suspicions about the
milkshake and so I took a sample.
I rushed it down to the lab.
I've got the lab report.
You're about to drink it right cause
you're thirsty. It's a hot day.
You love milkshakes and your roommates
says inside the envelope are facts about
this milkshake that if I promise
you it is indeed the case.
If you know the new these facts,
you would not drink the milkshake anymore.
And he'd say, Oh, thank God, don't open
the envelope and you drink the milkshake.
Disregarding the facts.
That's seems inappropriate.
Well,
if it really was true then that if only
we faced the facts about our mortality,
that we would live life
rather differently.
How could it be reasonable for
us to disregard those facts?
Well, that's the puzzle.
I may mask the puzzle.
Maybe we shouldn't call it a puzzle or
maybe the answer is that just shows the
options,
not really all that reputable.
What we either have to do is deny the
claims I've made about the nature of death
or else go on to ask
suppose that they are true.
How should we live in light of them?
Maybe the disregard option just as one
that we can't raise actually take on as a
intellectually acceptable alternative,
but I suspect that that's
probably a little bit too quick.
Yeah,
because really there are two different
ways in which facts could influence our
behavior and if we're not careful,
we'll disregard this distinction even
though I think it's an important one.
Here's the two ways.
On the one hand,
it could be that certain
facts if you knew them,
would cause you to behave differently
without actually giving you any reason to
behave differently.
That's possibility number one.
Possibility.
Number two is the facts change your
behavior by giving you a reason to behave
differently.
Let me show you an example of the first
possibility cause that's the one I think
we may be overlooking when we assume that
disregarding can't ever make any sense.
So there you are kissing,
making out with Peggy sue or Billy Bob,
whoever it is,
and your roommate birth centers
as I have in the envelope.
Certain facts such that if
you were to think about them,
you would no longer want to
kiss Peggy. Sue, Billy, Bob.
Let me just tell you what the facts and
the envelope are there certain facts
about the nature of Peggy Sue's
digestive system. Now, why not? You know,
you're making out after having had dinner
and while you're sitting there making
out food is making its way down.
Peggy Sue's digestive track being turned
into shit and eventually it's going to
be excreted. And if you started
picturing to yourself, uh, the feces, uh,
inside,
uh,
Peggy Sue's dad digestive track and the
fact that she's eventually going to be
wiping the feces off of her or behind you,
might find it difficult to continue to
engage in making out with Peggy sue.
It's not. So now these are just facts,
right? I didn't make any of this up,
but you know, there you are.
As I'm talking about them,
you're just being grossed out as
I described them. Now, does any,
do any of these facts about the digestive
system make it inappropriate to kiss
another human being? Oh, of
course not. But for all that,
thinking about those facts make it rather
difficult while you're thinking about
the facts to continue
enjoying kissing the person.
Yeah.
So there are certain facts
about the digestive tract,
such set. If you think about
them, you can't do something,
kiss the person.
But for all that,
it's not because you got any good reason
not to kiss the person. It's not that.
The facts about the human digestive
process give you reason not to kiss her.
They cause you to change your behavior
without giving you any reason to change
your behavior. So when the roommate
comes running in holding the envelope,
it says,
I have in this envelope certain facts
such that if you read these facts and
thought about these facts,
you would stop kissing this person.
The question you should
put to your roommate is,
are these facts that would merely caused
me to change what I'm doing or what are
the, are these facts things that would
give me some good reason to change?
You know,
if these are facts about how Peggy sue
likes to kiss and tell or then goes
around and talks about who's a
good kisser and who's a bad kisser,
maybe that gives you a reason to
not continue what you're doing.
So the facts could be things that would
give you reason to change your behavior,
but the mere fact that they would change
your behavior doesn't yet tell you
whether they're reason generating facts.
Yeah.
If they're mirror causes and not reasons
that maybe it's perfectly okay to
disregard them.
Your roommate comes in and starts
trying to tell you facts about the human
digestive system. You say, not now.
Okay.
Disregarding is sometimes
the appropriate thing to do.
Okay.
What about the fact about death?
Are the facts about death,
things that it's appropriate to disregard.
Okay.
A bold claim would say yes.
A bold claim would say
the facts about death.
If I thought about them would change my
behavior but not because it would give
me a reason to change my behavior simply
because it would influence my behavior
and given that we might say
better than I think about them,
that would be the bold
claim to make at this point.
Okay.
Suppose for example that you know the
the right way to live in light of the
facts about death is to live life
to the fullest. But suppose if,
if you think about death,
you just get too depressed and you
can't live life to the fullest.
It's not that the facts about death
give you reason to stay in your room and
Sulk,
it's just that the facts about death
caused you to stay in your room and salt.
If that was the case,
then district gardening
always disregarding the facts about death
might well be the appropriate response.
Well,
that would be a rather bold claim.
I'm not inclined to believe
that the bold claim is right.
Okay.
Should we conclude therefore that no,
you should always be thinking about the
facts about death. No, I'm a client.
I think that that other bold claim on the
other side is probably mistaken as raw
as well.
So there you are one more time,
one last time making out with
Peggy sue or Billy Bob and uh,
your roommate comes in and starts
trying to tell you about the fact that,
you know,
he's taken Shelly Kagan's a class on
death and he's been studying some biology
class and he wants to tell you about how
human bodies decay when they turn into
corpses. You know, as, as he
begins to tell you this story,
you start picturing Peggy
sue as a rotting corpse.
Suddenly, you know, you don't really
feel like kissing her anymore.
It sort of like the digestive track
story. It's not that, as far as I can see,
the fact that she's going to be a corpse
gives you any reason not to kiss her.
It's just that thinking about the fact
that she's going to be a corpse causes
you to not want to enjoy a case or
not be able to enjoy kissing her.
So I'm inclined to think that the right
position here is a kind of moderate one,
a modest one.
There are times and places for
thinking about the facts of death.
When you're kissing somebody
that is not the time,
and that is not the place,
the position that says you should always
have the fact of your mortality forever
before your mind's eye.
I think that's misguided.
Similarly though,
anybody who says you should never think
about the facts of mortality in the
nature of death,
I think that's misguided as well.
There's a time and place,
but that still leaves us
with the question. All right,
so I suppose this is the time and place.
You know,
if ever there was a time and place for
thinking about the facts of death and how
to influence our life,
it's right now in a class on death.
So we still have to face the question,
how should you live?
What is the appropriate response
to the facts about life and death?
That's the question we
have to turn to next time.